ASSISTANT SPECIAL WATERGATE
PROSECUTOR AND FORMER DOJ
NATIONAL SECURITY OFFICIAL AND
PROSECUTOR BRANDON.
GOOD EVENING TO ONE AND ALL.
LAURA, WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN ALL
MY LIFE?
MISS YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> I'VE BEEN CHEERING ON SERENA
WILLIAMS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M NOT EVEN MAD.
WE ALL HAVE BEEN.
LISTEN, LAURA, I'VE BEEN WANTING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
CAN YOU SUM UP WHAT THE TRUMP
TEAM IS ARGUING IN RESPONSE TO
THE DOJ BRIEF?
>> WELL, ONE, TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, NO, NO ONE THINKS
DONALD TRUMP IS ACTUALLY WRITING
A MEMOIR AND THAT'S WHY HE HAS
IN HIS POSSESSION AT MAR-A-LAGO
DOCUMENTS THAT OUGHT TO HAVE
BEEN RETURNED A LONG TIME AGO
BUT THEIR ARGUMENT IS SIMPLY
THIS.
WE DON'T TRUST YOU DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO HAVE CONDUCTED AN
INVESTIGATION TO HONOR WHATEVER
PRIVILEGE CLAIMS WE THINK WE
HAVE WHETHER GOOD OR NOT, WE
THINK IF YOUR TRUMP'S TEAM WE
HAVE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE CLAIMS
AND ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
YOU HAD A SEPARATE TEAM GO IN
AND TRY AND ENSURE THE GUARD
RAILS WERE UP AND COULDN'T SEE
THOSE, WE DON'T TRUST WE WANT
OUR OWN PERSON.
THE SECOND ARGUMENT IS THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE WAS
ANY SHOCK BY THE ARCHIVES OR
ANYONE ELSE THERE WERE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN THE
BOXES THAT WERE AT MAR-A-LAGO
BECAUSE OF COURSE, THEY'RE
CLASSIFIED AND PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS.
WHICH MAKES YOU SCRATCH YOUR
HEAD HERE, DON.
RIGHT?
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS WHOLE
EXERCISE HAS BEEN YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO HAVE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS, YOU'RE NO LONGER THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU'RE ON ONE HAND ADMITTING
YOU HAD THEM AND SAYING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE
CONTAINED IN THEM, YOU MADE THE
ARGUMENTS TO SUGGEST WHY YOU'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE HAD ANY OF
IT.
THIS WHOLE THING COMES DOWN,
THIS PARTICULAR MOTION THEY'RE
DOING NOW SAYS THEY WANT A
SPECIAL MASTER.
THEY DON'T TRUST THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
AND REALLY, WHAT THEY MADE THE
CASE FOR IS WHY THE ARCHIVES AND
DOJ CANNOT TRUST THEM TO HAVE
RETURNED ANYTHING THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO, ALL OF WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO OR GIVE SOME REASON
WHY THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO.
>> NICK, LET'S TALK A LITTLE
MORE ABOUT WHAT LAURA IS SAYING.
SHE'S SAYING TRUMP LAWYERS ARE
ARGUING CLASSIFIED MATERIALS
SHOULD HAVE BEEN EXPECTED TO BE
FOUND IN THOSE 15 BOXES TAKEN
FROM MAR-A-LAGO CLAIMING IT'S
THE NATURE.
DOES THAT ARGUMENT HOLD WATER
GIVEN THE TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS
AT ISSUE?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THIS IS STUFF THAT IS NATIONAL
SECURITY SECRETS.
AND I THINK WHAT REALLY CAUSED
THE ARCHIVES TO SEND THIS OVER
TO DOJ FOR AN INVESTIGATION
WASN'T JUST THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
BUT THAT THEY WERE MIXED IN WITH
A LOT OF OTHER IRRELEVANT
DOCUMENTS THAT JUST SHOWED THAT
THE WHOLE THING WAS ONE BIG
MESS.
AND SO THEY WERE CONCERNED AS TO
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHO WAS LOOKING AT
THEM, AND WHO HAD ACCESS TO
THEM.
IT MUCH MORE BEYOND AND BY THE
WAY, THE PAPERS THAT THE TRUMP
PEOPLE PUT IN JUST REFER TO THEM
AS SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS.
THEY TRY TO DOWN PLAY EVERYTHING
IN THIS BRIEF AND DON'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE AT ISSUE WITH THIS SEARCH
WARRANT.
>> EVERYTHING EXCEPT THEY WERE
HYPERVENTILATING NEAR THE VAPORS
ABOUT EXPIRED PASSPORTS AND TIME
MAGAZINE.
YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT WITH THAT,
NICK.
BRANDON, GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK
BECAUSE YOU SPECIALIZE IN
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
THE TRUMP TEAM IS EXPRESSING
OUTRAGE OVER THE PHOTO INCLUDED
THE DOJ FILING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
COLLECT EVIDENCE IN PARTICULAR
IF YOU'RE COLLECTING CLASSIFIED
EVIDENCE.
THIS ISN'T AN INDICATION OF WHAT
IT LOOKED LIKE.
THIS IS AN INDICATION TRYING TO
DEMONSTRATE THIS IS THE MATERIAL
SEIZED FROM THIS PARTICULAR
LOCATION AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT JUMPS OUT IS THESE COVER
SHEETS.
WHEN YOU HAVE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, THEY'RE NOT JUST
MARKED TOP SECRET OR SECRET,
THERE IS A COVER SHEET AND THE
POINT OF THAT COVER SHEET IS TO
SCREAM AT ANYONE IN THE ROOM
THAT THIS MATERIAL IS CLASSIFIED
SO YOU DON'T TRIP OVER IT SO
THAT THERE AREN'T ACCIDENTS.
WHEN YOU SEE THE COVER SHEETS
AND YOU LEARN THERE WERE
HUNDREDS OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, IT INDICATES IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT TO MISS THIS
MATERIAL.
>> SHOULDN'T -- I MEAN --
SHOULDN'T ALL OF THIS HAVE GONE
EITHER IN A SHREDDER OR BE
DISCARDED, HOWEVER IT IS THEY
HANDLE IT?
THERE IS A PROCESS FOR THIS AND
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE IT BEING
ON A FORMER PRESIDENT'S, YOU
KNOW, BEDSIDE TABLE OR DESK OR
WHATEVER, HOWEVER IT WAS STORED.
IT SHOULD BE SECURED AND UNDER
GOVERNMENT PROTECTION, AM I
WRONG ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, SO IT'S NOT -- I WOULD
TAKE IT A STEP BEYOND THAT WHICH
IS IT'S NOT ABOUT WHAT SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED ON JANUARY 20th
WITH RESPECT TO THE DOCUMENTS.
I THINK THE POINT WAS MADE
EARLIER IF ALL OF THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND I THINK
WE'RE AT OVER 300 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO, IF THEY
WERE ALL RETURNED TO THE
ARCHIVES IN JANUARY, WE WOULDN'T
BE HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
WE WOULDN'T BE HAVING A
DISCUSSION.
IT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE
DOCUMENTS ON JANUARY 20th.
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES, MANY CASES
OF HANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION OFTEN AREN'T
PROSECUTED.
PEOPLE DO MAKE MISTAKES.
IT'S WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THAT.
THAT'S A KEY POINT HERE THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S NOT THERE
WERE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THERE,
IT'S THAT THERE WAS NOTICE THAT
THERE WERE THESE DOCUMENTS THERE
ULTIMATELY THEY WERE NAMED.
>> LAURA, WHAT'S NOT IN HERE,
RIGHT, IS ANY MENTION OF
DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS OR
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNMENT
SAYING THAT TRUMP MOVED
DOCUMENTS AND TRIED TO OBSTRUCT
THE INVESTIGATION.
WHY IS THAT NOT IN THERE?
>> BECAUSE THERE IS NOT REALLY
LIKELY A LEGITIMATE DEFENSE TO
THOSE NOTIONS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO HONE IN AND BE
VERY NARROW IN THE FOCUS IN
FRONT OF THIS JUDGE.
THIS IS FOR THE AUDIENCE'S
CLARIFICATION, THIS IS NOT THE
SAME JUDGE THAT SIGNED OFF ON
THE SEARCH WARRANT.
THEY HAVE TO GIVE A DIFFERENT
JUDGE THE CONTEXT, THE
COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION TO
RULE ON THINGS THAT THEY WERE
ASKED ABOUT WHICH IS THE SPECIAL
MASTERS SO THEY'RE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON THE STRONGEST ARGUMENTS
THEY HAVE ARE IN FAVOR OF WHY
THEY BELIEVE A NEUTRAL FIGURE IN
A CASE SUCH AS THIS OF
EXTRAORDINARY PUBLIC INTEREST
OUGHT TO CHECK AND MAKE SURE
EVERY I WAS DOTTED AND T WAS
CROSSED.
I WANT TO UNDER STATE THE POINT
WE SHOULD NOT BE HERE.
WE SHOULD NOT BE HERE BECAUSE
THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
COOPERATION FROM A FORMER
PRESIDENT TO PROVIDE DOCUMENTS
BACK TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
YES, MISTAKES HAD BEEN MADE.
WE MOST NOTABLY HEAR THE ANALOGY
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
DOCUMENTS ON A PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER.
GUESS THE DISTINCTION?
THE REASON WE'RE HERE AND AN
EXECUTION OF THE SEARCH WARRANT
AND A LEGAL FILING SUGGESTING
ALL YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO DO HERE
IS NOT HAVE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
BUT GONE BACK TO THE ARCHIVES,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN STANDARD
BACK AND FORTH.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST.
IT NOT WHAT SHOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN AT ALL.
WE'RE DEALING WITH DOCUMENTS OF
THIS NATURE.
WE SHOULD NEVER BE HERE.
WE SHOULD NEVER KNOW ABOUT THIS.
THE STORY SHOULD HAVE ENDED WHEN
THE FIRST 15 BOXES WERE RETURNED
AND THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ALL OF
THEM.
>> IS THIS SIMILAR, LAURA, WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE DISTINCTION,
IS THERE A PRESIDING JUDGE AND
MAGISTRATE THAT RULES ON THINGS?
IS THAT HOW THIS WORKS?
>> DIFFERENT INTERMEDIATE
JUDGES.
ONE RULES WHETHER SEARCH
WARRANTS SHOULD BE EXECUTED.
THE TRIAL JUDGE IS USUALLY THE
FEDERAL DISTRICT JUDGE THAT WILL
HEAR THE CASE ULTIMATELY.
>> OKAY.
NICK, WHAT ABOUT THIS IDEA TRUMP
HAD AN EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY AT
HIS RESIDENCE, WHICH IS A GOLF
COURSE THAT'S OPEN TO MEMBERS
WHERE HE WAS APPARENTLY KEEPING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, THE
GOVERNMENT WANTED BACK KEEPING
THEM IN HIS DESK?
>> WELL, THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE FOURTH AMENDMENT.
THERE IS AN EXPECTATION TO
PRIVACY AND THE AMENDMENT
BASICALLY, THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
SAYS YOU'RE GOING TO BE SECURE
IN YOUR HOME AND POSSESSIONS AND
ANY SEARCHES HAVE TO BE
REASONABLE.
AND SO TO HAVE A REASONABLE
SEARCH, THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO
COME IN AS THEY DID HERE AND
PROVIDE PROBABLE CAUSE THERE WAS
EVIDENCE OF A CRIME, A CRIME HAD
BE COMMITTED AND EVIDENCE OF
THAT CRIME EXISTED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY CERTAINLY DID THAT AND THE
PROOF IS IN THE PUDDING IN WHAT
THEY CAME UP WITH AND TOOK.
THE PAPERS FILED TODAY
COMPLETELY TRIED TO DOWN PLAY
THE WHOLE BUSINESS ABOUT WHAT
OCCURRED IN JUNE AND THEN LATER
IN TERMS OF TURNING OVER OTHER
DOCUMENTS IN RESPONDING TO A
GRAND JURY SUBPOENA.
THEY TRY AND PORTRAY THIS AS
JUST THE USUAL GIVE AND TAKE
WHEN THE ARCHIVES GET INVOLVED
WITH THE PRESIDENT SETTING UP
PAPERS AND THIS WAS BASICALLY
JUST GIVING SECURITY ADVICE.
THAT'S HOW THEY PORTRAY WHAT IN
EFFECT IS CONCEALMENT IN A FALSE
AFFIDAVIT THAT WAS OFFERED BY
TRUMP'S OWN ATTORNEY SAYING THAT
THEY HAD DONE AN ADEQUATE SEARCH
AND LOOKED EVERYWHERE FOR ALL
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> BRANDON, BEFORE WE GET OUT OF
HERE, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM
THE DOJ?
WHAT WILL THEY DO NEXT?
>> THEY WILL DO WHAT THEY
CONTINUED TO DO.
THE SPECIAL MASTER AT MOST IS
GOING TO POTENTIALLY WITHHOLD
SOME SMALL AMOUNT OF DOCUMENTS
OR DELAY IT.
THE INVESTIGATION IS ON GOING.
ONE IS BEING LED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI WHERE THEY'RE
DETERMINING WHAT HAPPENED AND
WHY.
THEY'RE DETERMINING WHY THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE TAKEN
TO MAR-A-LAGO AND ALL PROVIDED
RETURNED TO THE ARCHIVES.
WHY THEY WEREN'T PROVIDED WHEN
THERE WAS A SUBPOENA.
WHY THERE WERE REPRESENTATIONS
MADE ON JUNE 3rd THAT ULTIMATELY
TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE.
THERE IS ALSO WHAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS DOING
AND IT'S NOT JUST TO DETERMINE
WHAT POTENTIAL RISKS THERE WERE
TO NATIONAL SECURITY AND HOW TO
MITIGATE THE RISKS.
THEY ARE DOING A CLASSIFICATION
REVIEW.
ARE THESE DOCUMENTS ACTUALLY
STILL CLASSIFIED?
THAT'S IRRELEVANT TO POTENTIAL
CHARGES.
THEY'RE FINGERPRINTING THESE
DOCUMENTS TRYING TO DETERMINE
CAN THEY DETERMINE WHO ACCESSED
THEM.
THAT IS RELEVANT TO POTENTIAL
CRIMIN